our glory and
our uniqueness and why we are as we are
is because we are a
plant animal symbiotic
species our ordinary state
our state of nature the way in which we
existed until 10
000 years ago was in a very tightly
bound symbiotic relationship
with plants they were we domesticated
them
and we uh spread them
and we created environments for them
through the use of
burning and in return for this
this mysterious connection opened up
where real information couched in
humanly cognizable terms
information about where the reindeer
went
who you should marry what the weather is
going to do
stuff like that real information began
to be traded
back and forth now biologists are
familiar with the notion of
pheromones message-bearing chemicals
that
regulate behavior within a species
but we're just getting ready to go to
the next level
and recognize the possibility of what
have been called exopheromones
pheromones that regulate behavior
between species
and it's very clear that you know in
climaxed ecosystems of great age
such as the equatorial tropics of this
planet
uh exopheromonal interactions
become the major mediating force
in all the evolutionary exchanges going
on
the old notion of competition
and survival of the fittest is now seen
to be bankrupt
the way nature works is it's the species
that can make itself
most necessary to other species
the one that can cut energy deals with
the most
of its neighbors that is the successful
one
so you maximize cooperation you maximize
dependency
you maximize integration this is the
successful
evolutionary strategy i mean of course
you can be a jaguar and crash around in
the forest and eat things immediately
smaller than you but jaguars will be a
memory in the fossil record of this
planet when the plants will
still exist given you know that man were
not
part of the picture so
uh the dynamic
of of life dictates that these
uh that these energy levels be held very
close
well no i think you know nothing is
outside of the natural
but all of this can be explained
uh in terms of climatological flux
on the african continent very briefly
um you know the primates evolved in
africa
out of the primates came the hominids
which were
these gray seal upright uh
opposable thumb binocular vision and
there were a number of these and they
existed for you know over the past six
million years
but africa and the planet because of
repeated glaciation
is subject to cycles of drying and
every time the ice moved south
primate populations were bottled up in
africa
and we know there have been four
glaciations immediately the last one the
ice melted 20 000 years ago
and out of africa that last time
came pastoralists people who
had domesticated cattle and had a style
of following
cattle around rather than being just
strictly hunter-gatherers
well i maintained what happened was
these arboreal tree canopy living apes
came under pressure
as the continent dried up to expand
their diet
because the forests were disappearing
and being replaced by grassland
well most animal species eat only one or
two kinds of
food this is a general rule in nature
and it's in order to hold down exposure
to mutagenic
influence but when an animal population
is in a situation of food scarcity the
logical thing to do is to begin to test
food sources and to expand your
repertoire of food
well that's what these primates coming
out of the trees did
number one they began eating meat which
gave them a real interest that they had
never had before
in these ungulate mammals that were
evolving in the grasslands
and they began to test all kinds of
other foods in the environment well when
you do that
you are exposing your population to
mutation
and mutation rates soar
and it was during this period
that the human brain size doubled
in like a million and a half years
someone said it was the
the most rapid evolutionary expansion
of a major organ ever seen
in the fossil record nothing like it
ever happened why what was making this
happen
well uh it looks like probably huge
numbers of mutations were taking place
in this population because people were
literally eating anything they could get
their hands on
and in this environment of the
grasslands the mushrooms were growing on
the dung of these ungulate animals
i mean i think we had something an
unimaginably precious
gift we had consciousness
and dynamic order
consciousness as we experience it now
within the confines of history
is most analogous to cancer
i mean it's just you know replicating
spreading
but it once was a dynamic
ordered thing people lived they died
they made love they had
children they herded their flocks they
had ecstatic flights into
dimensions which we cannot even conceive
of
and they felt no need you know to break
into the earth to divert the rivers to
do
all of this stuff you know
nature is just an ongoing story the very
drying
processes that created those grasslands
that created those pressures on diet
that created that mother goddess
religion that evolved those ungulate
animals
that process continued and the
grasslands dried up
and the winds began to blow and the
water holes got further and further
apart from each other
and the mushroom festivals went from
every saturday night
to the first saturday of every month
and then to four times a year and then
to once a year and then to once every
five years and then to never
and in the absence of the psychedelic
experience
this ego thing
gets going you know and you no longer
see things on a planetary scale or a
millennial scale or
it's just about you know my women my
money
my land my children all of this stuff
and at that point you get
um the appearance of
of historical civilizations you have
kingship
kingship you know the age of gilgamesh
i mean my god when you read the story of
gilgamesh you just wonder
what's going on uh gilgamesh
spurned the goddess
and the goddess sent a bull
which to me is you know symbolic of the
mystery of the mushroom the ungulate
herding horned animal the crypto symbol
for the god
the god is sensible and he he uh
rejects the bull he rejects the goddess
he rejects the bull
then he takes enkidu the shaman figure
and forces him to go with him
into the wilderness and what do they do
in the wilderness
this oldest of all myths this story of
the first men
what do they do they cut down the tree
of life
that's what they do they cut down the
tree of life
and then they you know it goes forward
the earliest strata
of mythology that comes out of these
middle eastern civilizations is
full of this male female
nature artificial tension
the story of genesis is a similar thing
i mean what's happening in genesis is
history's first drug bust
a woman is involved
with a plant and the plant
uh opens their eyes
and they see that they are naked which
happens to be
the case they are naked so in other
words they
they see they grok their true
existential condition
and yahweh wandering around mumbling to
himself in the garden
says this thing that these people have
done
what if they eat of the fruit of the
tree of life
then they will be as we are so it's very
clear
that there is concern
to withhold knowledge that
human beings are to be held in an
inferior
position otherwise if they were to eat
of the fruit of the tree of life
of knowledge they would be as we are so
there's this whole
tension and in the story in genesis
you'll recall adam and eve were cast out
of eden
and an angel is set at the east of eden
with a burning sword
well what i take this to be about is the
it's a story from a strata
where already the shift to the dominator
culture has taken place
but they're looking backward at the
partnership
society in on the grasslands of africa
and the and the angel with the burning
sword is nothing more than
the sun that they literally were cast
out of eden eden disappeared around them
it dried up and blew away
and there was nowhere to go but the nile
valley and palestine
and these people who appear in the nile
valley in palestine at about 9800 bc
called not to faye and come out of
nowhere
with a very high culture and a
tremendous ability
to exploit plant resources and i think
they are the remnants
of this partnership culture and you see
our
our the way in which all this ties into
the present and
attempts to be more than just a uh
you know a kind of cultural
reconstruction of pre-history
is we're trying to understand who we are
why we are the way we are
we are very very restless and the
path of our restless frantic
peregrinations
across the intellectual landscape is
what we call history
you know it's our effort to try and get
straight get back to
something which we feel we deserve and
that we lost
and that we don't know quite what it was
well
meanwhile in the rain forests in the
arctic tundra
these little brown people have been
keeping
the gnosis going never questioning
never doubting millennia after millennia
going into these hyperdimensional mind
spaces
and operating there
you